this old barrack in Gdansk was
originally a torpedo warehouse located
some 500 kilometers from Berlin this is
where the Iron Curtain began to crumble
back then this was still called the
Lenin shipyard today it's still used for
welding hammering shortening or
lengthening ships the smell of rust and
iron hangs in the sea air here we find
the European solidarity center the heart
of liberal Poland we meet the hero of
the salad Ornish movements lash phones
still a nonconformist even the shirt he
is wearing seems to be an open challenge
directed at Poland's current governments
it reads Constitution in quotation marks
Nobel Peace Prize winner and former
Polish presidents back then co founder
and leader of the Solidarity movement
you see I grew up without a father I'm
sure he would have looked after me and
then I probably would have become the
director of the shipyard and not just a
worker
I'm euro but deacon well I would
certainly cut out for it I instead I
became an electrician but one who
challenged the director here head-on and
became famous now you tell me was that
good or bad in the summer of 1980 less
Forenza joined the striking workers the
norms were too high the shops were too
empty the work was too dangerous they
were also fighting for their rights and
for freedom just like today after 18
days the communist government was
brought to its knees in this room less
Forenza signed the agreements with a
noticeably large pin salad Arnage the
first independent trade union in the
soviet bloc was born for feeling
technically speaking it was our solid
Arnage movement that eventually led to
the fall of the wall but political
leaders at the time and the whole world
could see that communism was coming to
an end the time was ripe for change
in the spring of 2019 salad Anna
celebrated its 13th annual round table
a further polish Democratic convention
the anniversary was marked by a
container outside the center the
Conservative government did not send any
form of congratulation at telling
absence the government is more concerned
with supporting people like Albert
Valesky he lives in eastern Poland where
birth rates are higher and church pews
are fuller his home village has just
over 2,000 residents virtually all of
whom voted for the national conservative
law and justice or peace party the
farmer says peace keeps its promises I
voted for the peace party in 2015 I'll
keep voting for them because I believe
they'll do everything to keep the
villages in Poland strong the party came
to power in 2015 thanks largely to the
500-plus program under which families
receive five hundred zloty per child per
month along with free schoolbooks and
money for school starters except to help
people get up from their knees as they
say in Poland we can tell by our wallets
money is benefiting our children it's
for additional tutoring and classes and
for vacation the money from the state
which receives generous subsidies from
the European Union makes life more
comfortable for the farmers and yet the
burlap ski family wouldn't say they're
grateful that communism ended and the
iron curtain fell they feel the former
hero less Forenza betrayed them and made
a deal with the Communists when Lakeway
Enza was president he invited foreign
investors in the polling back then that
might have been a good idea but they let
too many in too many Polish people were
sold out thank goodness the peace put an
end to that
[ __ ] today the Polish capital Warsaw is
like a portfolio exhibition it's a city
of global conglomerates they're sleek
cosmopolitan skyscrapers would fit
anywhere in the world the city has
changed beyond recognition since the
fall of communism German car
manufacturers Chinese banks American
consultants a reporter asks has Poland
sold itself out this is a different
world a new world for anyone with enough
motivation power and finances can take
whatever they want things aren't good
the way they are we lack rules but I'm
sure it'll sort itself out in 100 years
but left's keys home village is hosting
an agricultural trade show they are all
proud of their new prosperity they can
keep up with the rest of Europe at least
when it comes to agriculture even if
they are peace folders now living in a
unified Europe is a given 30 years ago
that wasn't the case the founding of
that first trade union in the port city
of Gdansk all those years ago set off a
historical chain reaction between the
East and West that led to the end of the
Iron Curtain